welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and this is a breakdown of Star
Wars Rebels season one among Ahsoka the
Mandalorian and the various other Star
Wars live action titles they are all
essentially thanks to Dave filoni
live-action spin-offs of rebels so
whether you've seen this show or not we
are doing this four-part Rebels re-watch
to catch everyone up on the Easter eggs
the plot points the unanswered questions
from this series like how does Chopper
sleep at night and by the end of this
breakdown you'll be able to go into
shows like Ahsoka with a cheat sheet of
what you really need to know also please
subscribe to the break room channel for
our upcoming Ahsoka after show Wookie
leaks let's get started with season 1
episode 1 and 2 spark of the Rebellion
Parts one and two this two-part series
premiere opens on the Triangular holes
of three Imperial Star Destroyers
looking like sharp teeth of the jaws of
a beast chomping down on the Stars
devouring the Galaxy George Lucas is
opening shot for a New Hope was also a
star destroyer bearing down on us and
that's where this Rebel series wants to
put us emotionally James Earl Jones
returns to voice Darth Vader whose mask
we see in a massive screen encompassing
hologram the Jedi are all but destroyed
and yet your task is not complete
Inquisitor in the bald head position
right invader's breathing vent breathing
down on his shoulders and his head is
that of The Inquisitor or the grand
Inquisitor voiced by Jason Isaacs the
udapowan race scene in Revenge of the
Sith and the Obi-Wan Kenobi series he
was played by Rupert Friend but they
really didn't do enough to stretch out
his face while he would go on to be
known as the grand Inquisitor at first
in this Rebel series the character was
known as just The Inquisitor originally
Rebels wasn't going to have Darth Vader
at all but they decided to add this
prologue and the epilogue of the series
for context and star warsness lucasfilm
released rebels in October 2014 on
Disney XD after Clone Wars was
discontinued on the Cartoon Network in
2013 with an unfinished season 6 Arc
move to Netflix Rebels would sit around
all new characters and be set in five
BBY that's five years before A New Hope
in about 14 years after Revenge of the
Sith over the course of this series
would progress ahead to right before A
New Hope Ezra Bridger the hero really of
this series voiced by Taylor Gray looks
out from a tower on the Outer Rim world
of lothal this backdrop is kind of
Ezra's binary Sunset it returns
throughout the series specifically in
the final shot of the series and we'll
see it in the Ahsoka series and Ahsoka
the character will be played by Iman
espandi Ezra's view of the Star
Destroyer blast The Imperial March
yes really all of John Williams themes
just come back throughout this series so
I'm not gonna be pointing out every
instance nor will they point out like
every species every ship every Droid
every little bit of random orbash I'm
really just gonna focus on the major
major stuff that you need to know for
the other titles and the really really
cool Easter eggs that I don't really
think anyone else has pointed out before
so lothal is currently under Imperial
occupation and so we see all over the
place propaganda like this mural with
orabesh text support your Empire build
Tie fighters the latest in defense
against threats to peace sign off Fleet
systems bringing jobs and prosperity to
lothal this is really what lothal is
currently used for by the Empire sign
our Fleet systems the company that
builds Tie fighters later thrawn will
use lothal and had he been successful in
that operation the Empire might not have
lost the Civil War Ezra whose Force
sensitive census's future Master Kanan
Jairus voiced by Freddie Prince Jr
oh
yeah I love this sound effect of Ezra
sensing the force and it's presented as
kind of a force of nature here almost
like a whale call in the hyperspace
whales the pergil will play a very
important role in Ezra's Destiny and
will appear in the Ahsoka series Kanan
Jairus is the Alias of the former Jedi
Caleb Doom a princess to depa palaba and
their tragic Order 66 moment was
depicted in the very first episode of
the bad batch series also in his crew
here in the streets of lothal is Zeb
aurelios The lasat Voice by Steve Bloom
who also showed up in live action with
Incredible VFX in the Mandalorian season
3 and the Mandalorian character Sabine
Wren voiced in this series by Tia sirkar
who is played in Ahsoka by Natasha Louis
bordizo Sabine is quite the artist her
armor features the Mandalorian starboard
symbol the orbash number five for her
code name being Specter 5 and a night
owl style helmet the same kind of style
worn by Bo Katan Ezra interrupts these
Rebels mission to steal blasters leading
to this Chase through the lothal streets
and down the highway they get scooped up
by the ghost State vcx 100 light braider
captained by Twilight Hera sundula
voiced by Vanessa Marshall in this show
and played by Mary Elizabeth Winstead
and Ahsoka and their Astromech droid is
Chopper voiced by Dave vellone himself
and as we'll see in pretty much every
episode of the series Chopper is just
kind of a jerk he's always picking
fights and committing more crimes Ezra
finds a lightsaber and Jedi holocron
that has a message to all Jedi from
Obi-Wan Kenobi right after the purge and
Obi-Wan here is voiced by James Arnold
Taylor doing a pretty solid impression
of Ewan McGregor this is Master Obi-Wan
Kenobi I regret to report that both are
Jedi Order and the Republic have fallen
but it's interesting how in the super
Premiere we only hear the first half of
it here we don't get the full message of
Hope just yet now these blasters are
sold to Crime Lord visago in exchange
for food and nympho about Wookie
prisoners ghost crew tries to pull the
old Wookie prisoner con that Han and
Chewie pulled in A New Hope except Kanan
and Sabine pretend that Zeb is a rare
hairless Wookie haven't you ever seen a
rare hairless Wookie before
it's all a trap though and Ezra gets
captured by agent callus voice bite the
amazing actor Davido yellow the crew
goes back for Ezra who had overheard
where The Wookie prisoners are because
he's such a crafty thief and voice
impersonator on Stolen radio comms so
the wookies are being sent into slave
labor in the spice mines on the planet
Kessel of Kessel Run Fame and would be
shown a few years later in live action
in the solo film they free these Wookies
and Kingdom Reveals His Jedi skills we
get a little Wilhelm scream when Ezra
rescues a Wookie kid and Kanan offers to
train Ezra in the ways of the force and
we hear the rest of Obi-Wan's hopeful
message and how it's not just a warning
it's a message of Hope and advice on how
to move forward from this the future is
uncertain we will each be challenged our
trust our faith our friendships and in
time A New Hope will emerge ah a new
hope it's the name of the movie okay
episode 3 droids in distress the ghost
crew plots to steal ion disrupters from
Minister makheth Tua natua is a
character that appears in the thrawn
novel and in a few Star Wars comics R2D2
and C-3PO Cameo so folks season 1 of
rebels and attempt to win over Star Wars
fans often just plugged in random faces
from the OT but my favorite Cameo here
is to Droid piloting this Gorel
transport rx24 voiced by The Wonderful
Paul Rubens who we just lost I am sorry
sir your Astromech must proceed to the
back of the craft Rubens is an important
voice to Star Wars history he provided
the voice of r3x or X from the original
Star Tours ride at Disneyland and r3x
now serves as a DJ at Olga's Cantina in
Galaxy's Edge 3PO and R2 translate for
TOA and they end up on board the ghosts
we learned that ion disruptors are the
weapons that wiped out most of zeb's
people the lasat so he's wary about this
deal the callus shows up during their
meeting with visago and taunt Zeb with a
bow rifle that he says he took off
al-assad and he says that he's the one
who gave the order to use those Zion
disruptors on them all and Zeb loses it
and while zeb's about to lose his fight
Ezra of force pushes kallus away from
Zeb and the crew Returns the protocol
and Astromech droids 2 their owner
Senator Baylor Ghana the final shot of
this episode mirrors Leia recording her
message to Obi-Wan on R2 in A New Hope
okay episode 4 fighter flight Ezra and
Zeb after some squabbling go on a melee
run run the melee Run Fruit come back
throughout live-action Star Wars titles
stapaloni loves these and you can
actually get a drink based on the melee
run at Galaxy's Edge it's so good yeah
this episode is kind of all about the
fruit the fruit really is one of the
simple joys of being a rebel folks and
the shopping list that Hera gives them
includes science dip space waffles large
bag writing Cam and Ill pickles Ezra
runs into family friend Morad sumar and
Zeb and has refined a crate of melee run
and Ezra gets caught stealing one of
them they escaping a TIE fighter while
Hera and Kanan hang out back on the
ghost plane Hollow chess Zeb and Ezra
chased down the prisoner Convoy in the
tie
yeah zeb's trying to pull off some
classic Jedi Mind Tricks the way Ezra
has been scratching the surface of using
the force these first four episodes this
Imperial troop transport we see is
actually based on a classic Star Wars
toy well you know where the people kind
of plug into the sides of it and we see
how Sabine graffitied a mural of Zeb and
Ezra and Chopper she is such a talented
artist something that will come back in
the final scene of the series throughout
the show you do get shots of her room
that includes characters that look a lot
like CAD Bane and embo from Clone Wars
episode 5 rise of the Old Masters so
this is an important episode please
watch this one if you can it's really
good Kanan trains as we're using these
same methods that Yoda uses with Luke
Skywalker and Empire the one-armed
handstand and this line do or do not
there is no try what does that even mean
so these Yoda anecdotes will be
important to Ezra since he later
communes with the Jedi Master and this
episode explores really the deeper
meaning of that quote from Empire which
I think often goes misunderstood because
I think people think that if you can't
actually accomplish something you
shouldn't even try that's not really
what it means it really means begin with
the ending mind see your target
actualize it believe in yourself and set
your Target on the destination don't
prematurely commit yourself to a half
measure Ezra nearly falls to his
freaking death from this training and
pitching machine Chopper fires another
bottle at Ezra it lands on a lost cat
and these fuzzballs are beloved
creatures that polony loves to bring
back in live action I'm sure we can see
quite a few low cats in Ahsoka the
Imperial news channel gets hijacked by
the anti-empire senator and Exile Travis
voiced by Brent Spiner from Star Trek
the Next Generation spymaster luminar
and Dooley is apparently imprisoned in
the spire luminar and Dooley first
appeared in Attack of the Clones and she
showed up in Clone Wars as the master of
Baris offy the young Jedi who framed
Ahsoka Tano for the bombing of the Jedi
Temple which led to Ahsoka leaving the
Jedi Order the Spire meanwhile is where
Maul was actually held in the comic
Darth Maul son of dathomir where he was
imprisoned by Darth Sidious in the part
of the timeline that's set after Clone
Wars season five Kanan and Ezra make it
to unduly sell and realize that it's not
actually her it's a corpse and the grand
Inquisitor was using her Essence to lure
in the Jedi as Kanan and The Inquisitor
duel link
emphasis was always on form three
you favor till ridiculous degree clearly
you were a poor student now this
Inquisitor used to be a Jedi Temple
guard and he was there for the trials of
Ahsoka in Paris in that Clone Wars ARC
and he mentions form three there are
seven total forms of lightsaber combat
and form three is the most defensive one
and this is also the first time we see
the inquisitors rotating a double-bladed
lightsaber put to use felony introduced
these as kind of a step up from Maul's
double-sided saber and Phantom Menace
this one spins they escape with the help
of Hera and some horny tibetes
nativity's got their name from the
abbreviation TBD or to be determined the
production team was using DVD as a
placeholder name and they decided to
just go with it which is kind of how a
lot of stuff in Star Wars Works Kanan
discovers a new understanding of Yoda's
quote I'm not gonna try to teach you
anymore if all I do is try that means I
don't truly believe I can succeed so
from now on I will teach you I may fail
you may fail but there is no try so this
wisdom is as much for the teacher as it
is for the student as Yoda will later
explain and Last Jedi which I think is
my favorite quote from the sequel
Trilogy failure also yes failure most of
all the greatest teacher failure is we
are what they grow Beyond
that is the true burden of all Masters
so really Yoda's wisdom is the rise of
the Old Masters in this episode's title
okay episode six breaking ranks Ezra
goes undercover at an imperial Academy
posing his Cadet named Dev Morgan to
steal a key card to stop a shipment of
kyber crystals which power lightsabers
and eventually power the Death Star
which is why at the end of this episode
the transport explodes releasing a wild
green Shockwave Ezra and the other
Cadets are tested using this well its
design is inspired by Clone Wars
episodes with the clone troopers clone
Cadets and the Box the clone troopers
have all since been decommissioned
excluding the bad batch some of whom are
still alive at this point in the
timeline as well as Rex whom will meet
in future seasons of rebels and I guess
that Homeless one that Obi-Wan ran into
and Obi-Wan Kenobi series but they've
all been replaced with Imperial recruits
in the form of Stormtroopers and this is
how they're trained Ezra gets kallus's
key card to the ghost crew but he stays
behind to break out his friends jaikel
and Zara leonis who's actually also
undercover trying to find his sister
Dara who went missing from the academy
the grand Inquisitor is coming the next
day to take custody of Ezra and Jai and
the three fight their way out of the
academy and atsd with the help of the
ghost crew but there decides to stay
behind to continue to search for his
sister and he faces the grand
inquisitor's questioning now long time
new Rockstar's viewers know how much we
use geology and how long we've been
using it for but if this is your first
time hearing about geology get ready for
Blockbuster quality skincare on a
student film budget geology is a 23-time
award-winning skin hair and body care
company recognized in men's health Oprah
daily hypebeast birdie Esquire and GQ
geology's products are just a handful of
powerful proven ingredients that have
been trusted by dermatologists for
decades geology can help you fight acne
reduce oiliness prevent wrinkles combat
dark or puffy under eyes have smoother
hydrated skin and Target signs of aging
everything you need to keep your skin
healthy no matter how much you soak in
the pool this summer don't know where to
start geology can create a simple and
effective skin care or hair care routine
for you all you gotta do is take a quick
30 second quiz right now if you use the
code new rockstars 100 geology will give
you 100 off their award-winning skin
care trial set you'll also get an
additional bonus offer of up to 30 off
one skin hair or body products when you
add it to your trial it's truly a while
to offer one of the best they've ever
given our audience so click the link in
the description or go to
geolog.i.e
rockstars100 to get started episode 7
out of Darkness so the Phantom which is
a small ship attached to the ghost gets
damaged in this episode Zeb fails to
notice the leak so Hera and Sabine take
the fandom to collect supplies from a
contact named fulcrum on Fort and axis
which is an abandoned asteroid base and
an axis will later be Revisited in a bad
batch Arc of Clone Wars season 7 which
is said years before this when the base
was still active during the Clone Wars
in their fight against droid army the
separatists Hera and Sabine find
fulcrum's crates marked with a fulcrum
symbol which yes does look a bit like a
certain to gruda's head more on that
later of course but anaxis is infested
with fear Knox which are deadly and
sunlight averse with an asteroid about
to block out the sun and the Phantom out
of fuel Hera and Sabine have to use the
explosive rhydonium to hold them off
right Fredonia was actually seen in the
season five abifar episodes of Clone
Wars in this episode we also finally get
to see some space waffles which were on
Hera's shopping list in episode 4
Galaxy's Edge needs these on the menu
okay episode 8 Empire day Kanan trains
Ezra to use the force to connect with a
loath cat but Ezra can't focus because
it's empire Day celebrating the founding
of the Empire 15 years ago we also find
out that it's the same day as Ezra's
birthday he turned 15. he was born the
day the empire was bounded and eight
years ago is when the Empire took his
parents Ephraim and Mira he hasn't seen
them since he's an orphan kind of like
Aladdin we see the Imperial holonet
broadcast which I am fascinated by we
get a look at Palpatine and this image
in the broadcast is from his younger
days before he became you know a hunched
raisin that shoots lightning showing how
really Imperial propaganda is hiding in
his true appearance I like the orabesh
ticker here it translates to Resonance
attacked by herd of rabid loaf cats
tragedy at boo boo Barn also partis
propaganda is the music on this
broadcast which also we hear during the
parade an upbeat version of The Imperial
March by composer Kevin Kleiner
so this music is something that exists
in Universe for the characters we also
heard this Imperial Propaganda music in
Solo the ghost crew throw grenades that
turn out to be fireworks diversions
later when the two death stars blow up
in the original timeline those
explosions are kind of celebrated as
literal fireworks in the sky Tua and
oresko show off the new synar Thai
Advance V1 the rebels blow it up Ezra
takes them to his old house where they
find sibo that's the missing rodian of
this episode The Empire put Tech in his
head it's given him access to schematics
battle plans including atats or at hats
tie interceptors and Sabine mentions an
encrypted file talking about A Five-Year
Plan for outer rim planets which might
refer to project Stardust that's a plan
to build the Death Star because about
five years from now is when that will go
online they get sibo off the planet and
he reveals he knows what happens to
Ezra's parents to be continued and we
pick up from there in episode 9
Gathering forces when Tie fighters are
now chasing The Ghost and sibo tells
Ezra that Troopers took his parents away
he was too afraid to stop them but to
help raise Ezra and Ezra is pissed The
Inquisitor is attached an xx23s thread
tracker to the Phantom right before the
ghost jumps to hyperspace the S red
tracker was first introduced in kraken's
Rebel Field Guide which is a 1991 Star
Wars RPG guidebook sibo knows there's a
tracker on board though and Kate and
Ezra detached the Phantom mid hyperspace
to misdirect The Inquisitor they take
the Phantom to an axis where Ezra tries
to connect with the fear knocks using
the force an animal taming ability that
Star Wars titles have been exploring
more and more like grogu with the rancor
Ezra admits that he's not afraid of the
fear knocks he's afraid of not knowing
the truth about his parents so he
forgives sibo and he tames these beasts
look at Ezra in a way I'm only trying to
get my dog Darla to do with me but she
won't the fear knocks occupy the
Stormtroopers while the grand Inquisitor
fights Kanan gives him the business Ezra
unsummons the alpha fear knock using
some dark side of the force Powers they
managed to escape but uh oh keep this in
mind Ezra's Dark Side Affinity just
becomes increasingly important
throughout the series but this episode
ends with Sabine giving us a bit of Hope
restoring an image of Ezra with his
parents episode 10 path of the Jedi
another important one Kanan brings Ezra
to a hidden Jedi Temple on lothal after
that dark side of the force incident the
temple demands both master and Padawan
open it together but once they're inside
Ezra must face the challenges alone in a
way he kind of has to save his master
it's actually kind of similar to Luke
Skywalker's cave quest in Empire Strikes
Back or Rey in that cave and ochtoe in
The Last Jedi like Luke and Ray Ezra
faces his worst fears and his
insecurities a vision of Kanan killed by
The Inquisitor and then the ghost crew
talk it's a major about him
Inquisitor Slaughters them too but Ezra
manages to snap himself out of it to
make it through the first two challenges
and he hears Yoda's voice once again
voiced by Frank Oz big fears have you
faced young one who are you
a guide Yoda also guides kanan's
insecurities as a master because it's as
important to teach the Master Yoda is an
exile on Dagobah at this point in
history so it's just kind of nice to
hear that he mentally calls out to so
many Jedi survivors scattered across the
Galaxy during this point in history in
the temple we see etchings on the walls
these were actually inspired by Ralph
McCoy's illustration in The Illustrated
Star Wars Universe from 1995 and it
seems like we'll learn more about these
kinds of etchings in Ahsoka Ezra
acquires a kyber crystal for his future
lightsaber and when Ezra asks Kanan if
they should use the temple as a base
Kanan just says I know what's in there
the past the past because he knows the
Jedi already tried to use the Jedi
Temple as a sanctuary the Jedi Temple on
Coruscant the one that was purged and
Obi-Wan explained in his message the
Jedi are now on A New Path they are
homeless Nomads episode 11 idiots array
it's the Lando episode Billy D Williams
returns to voices of famous Smuggler
beating Zeb in a game of sebach and
winning Chopper name is Calrissian
Orlando Calrissian now please introduce
me to my new Droid his winning hand is
idiot's array it's a winning hand in the
game of sebach the rules of the game
were detailed in the Lando novel from
1983. the crew joins Lando on a
smuggling run and they meet as Morgan
voiced by the great James Hong who
recently appeared in everything
everywhere at once his design was
inspired by an early Ralph McCory design
for Jabba the Hutt actually I have what
you ordered
what do you have to offer and return
Lando offers Hera too as Morgan but it's
part of his supposed plan to get a
puffer Pig who can detect Precious
Minerals and puffs up when it gets
scared Hera does manage to escape and
makes it back to the ghost where she
punches Landover using her the ghost
gets past the Imperial blockade and
returns to lothal whereas Morgan waits
for them his big shootout and Ezra
Reveals His new lightsaber but it's also
a Blaster gun which you know every
lightsaber should have that
functionality they drive as Morgan off
and they leave Landon behind with this
piggy episode 12 vision of hope so Ezra
has a vision of Senator and Exile Travis
including the crew helping Travis hide
and Travis mentioning Ezra's parents
which matches up with Travis's
conveniently timed coded broadcast that
he is actually headed to lothal so they
think they must meet up with him Ezra
meets up with Zaire who says that kallus
gathered troops at the old Senate
building and the rebels try to warn
Travis that kallus is setting up a trap
but kallus and Tua are one step ahead of
them with Intel on all of the rebels
they escape into the sewers with Travis
who reveals himself to be an Imperial
spy son of a he used the those
Transmissions to smoke out Rebel
sympathizers Senator B Travis also tells
Ezra that his parents are long dead your
parents were very brave
and very foolish where are they now I'll
tell you my boy they're gone but
good news is here a suspected Travis was
suss and she punched him after giving
him a dud Blaster so they escaped kallus
and the Stormtroopers and Ezra through
the blades that fan throws one Epic
Death Stare back at Travis before he
takes off episode 13 call to action so
The Inquisitor antua and callus greet
Grand Moff Tarkin on lothal so Tarkin
asks why the rebels keep making gains
and Clone Wars Tarkin was still just an
admiral but bad batch kind of shows them
in that transition from then to now here
we see him wearing armor similar to a
general veers war and Empire Strikes
Back Travis outs the ghost crew to the
public with the reward for their capture
so they can't hide in plain sight
anymore maybe you should change your arm
or Sabine and Kanan Clans to send a
message hijacking Imperial broadcast
from a communication tower on lothal but
Tarkin allows The Inquisitor to execute
oresco and Grint Tarkin facing away from
them underlining this really is a
message to Tua and kallus to get their
together Ezra finally connects to a
loaf cat to clear a probe Droid but they
end up getting recorded by the playback
The Inquisitor ambushes them at the
tower capturing Kanan but Ezra manages
to transmit an inspiring call to action
stand up together
and although the tower gets blown up the
final seconds of this episode and not
with the theme music but with this
interesting bait out sound effect this
isn't over no it isn't
I like to think their radio message was
still playing over Hera and Ezra's final
exchange there and that authentic
uncertainty that hot mic moment also
went out to inspire the people episode
14 Rebel resolve fulcrum tells Hera you
must stop your search
voice is sounding more feminine showing
how they're getting closer to revealing
her identity Ahsoka Tano also had to
forget about her Jedi Master and go into
hiding after Order 66 they intercept the
Droid Courier and swap it with chopper
who infiltrates the Imperial systems and
steals some info Chopper pushes an
Astromech off the ghost zeb's reaction
here is just great but that Astromech
survives he just kind of trembles
between two low-cuts still pretty mean
for Chopper to do that they read the
file on k n and lists his past crimes
including theft of Imperial supplies
resisting arrest assaulting officers and
piloting without a license after some
torture Kanan is taken to Mustafar
current home to Darth Vader's castle and
Hera describes it as far as where Jedi
go to die as it was here where the Jedi
Anakin was overtaken killed if you will
by this Sith Lord Vader and episode 15
fire across the Galaxy the season one
finale the ghost crew steals an imperial
transport and as it takes off the smoke
exhaust and dust forms the curved
swooshes of the Rebel Insignia nice
touch there the tie that Ezra and Zeb
stole on the fall and episode 4 comes
back but Sabine has painted it making it
look as ridiculously flashy and dumbass
you know a spy trying to blend in wood
if she painted her Mandalorian armor
that way whatever this shows for kids
The Inquisitor knows that physical
torture isn't working so he's using
kanan's guilt over abandoning his master
and the Jedi to try to break him Caleb
recalls defa's last word to him run
again this is something we will actually
see in the bad patch it's a
heartbreaking moment the rebels use
pulse detonators to disable Tarkin Star
Destroyer reinforcements are sent in
though so Chopper contacts fulcrum and
every time we see her her Hood I think
back in 2014 I just remember thinking
this is probably Leia right but the
reveal of who really is so much better
Ezra freeze Kanan and The Inquisitor is
waiting for them both the three of them
duel with lightsabers Kanan at one point
using as Ezra at one point using kanans
it's a two-on-one duel evoking the
climax of phantom menace it's so great
and Ezra gets thrown off the bridge
Kanan thinks he's dead and thinking he
has nothing left to fear he's able to
beat back The Inquisitor an Inquisitor
throws himself into the fire leaving us
with some chilling final words I have no
idea what you've unleashed here today
there are some things far more
frightening than death ah in this one
line we sense the tortured light that
these inquisitors lived when they're
living under Vader and the emperor the
rebels are saved by some corellian
Cruisers with the hollow projection of
Senator bail Organa and finally revealed
the agent fulcrum who's not Leia Organa
but Ahsoka Tano so what happens now I
don't know
one chapter has closed for you Ezra
Bridger this is a new day a new
beginning in 2014 we had last seen
Ahsoka in the Clone Wars series season 5
leaving Anakin behind there were some
unfinished storylines that were going to
be released on Netflix but it was so
cool to see her again now in 2020
ahsoka's immediate aftermath of Clone
Wars season 5 was shown in Clone Wars
final season season 7 on Disney plus
ahsoka's time in between would be
explored in the 2016 e.k Johnson novel
Ahsoka part of which was adapted in an
episode of tales of the Jedi in 2022 but
here they have aged up sniffs by 15
years she's got longer Snips the stripes
are stretched downwards still voiced by
Ashley Eckstein though Rosario Dawson
plays her in live action now really the
character just keeps showing up at all
different times in history as season one
began with Vader's face so it ends as
Tarson tells kallus that the emperor has
sent an alternative solution and whereas
episode 13 ended with the broadcast
dying out over the title now episode 15
ends with this sound
[Music]
oh
really Rebel season one I think was
still finding its footing it was fun but
it really just gets better from here
season two will Explore More of the
ghost cruise backstories but coming out
of season one I want to leave you guys
with a cheat sheet of some need to know
information for other Star Wars titles
starting with must watch episodes you
should watch all of them but if you only
have time for a few of them watch these
episode 5 rise to the Old Masters I
guess episode 8 Empire day just because
it's a really cool depiction of Imperial
propaganda and episode 10 path of the
Jedi also lothal it's one of the most
important planets in Star Wars as a
place where the empire built much of
their hardware and it contains a secret
Jedi Temple Yoda instilled among these
Heroes Complex Master Apprentice
relationships and the teachers struggle
just as much as the students do also the
inquisitors lived tortured existences
and they're still out there also Ahsoka
Tano has worn many hats over the years
Jedi Clone Wars Warrior Mandalore
Liberator farmer spy Rebel teacher and
now I guess some kind of Monk we're
going to talk a lot more about Ahsoka
coming up and lastly those cats are
awesome Mei Lu run are delicious and
Shopper's an please subscribe to
all three channels on the new rockstars
Network and you can follow me on all
social platforms at eavos stay tuned for
our breakdown of variable season 2 and
all of our coverage of Ahsoka thanks for
watching and I'll see you next time bye